so there are a million censorship
stories out there but every once in a
while you see one that's just like
actually pretty unbelievable and this is
one of them so amber athey was a talk
show host on a conservative news station
in washington called wmal it's a good
station
then she made the mistake of tweeting a
joke about the color of kamala harris's
pantsuit during the state of the union
we're just going to read it to you
because it's like it's not anything to
be embarrassed enough here's what it
said quote kamala harris looks like a
ups employee what can brown do for you
nothing good apparently
okay so that's a joke based on the ups
slogan it's like not that far out it's
certainly not hateful
but a few days later a left-wing
activist group pretended that they were
deeply upset because it was racist so
they called on cumulus which owns wml to
fire her and she was fired and unlike
most people get fired she fought back in
a big way she's got a great piece in
this in the spectator of london today
she joins us
right now amber thanks so much for
coming on are we it feels like in this
story we're missing
part of it like that that's the tweet
and then you get fired on what grounds
yeah it's a great point tucker i wish
that there was more to the story because
this is so infuriating but i have a
termination letter that lays out in very
specific detail that it was in fact this
tweet about kamala harris's outfit and i
think what happened here is that cumulus
thought in cumulus is the parent company
for wmal as you mentioned
that they could just make this all go
away they could get these few activist
emails they could appease the mob if
they just fired me well their first
mistake was that the woke mob is never
satisfied they always want more scalps
and the second mistake that they made is
they thought that i was just going to
roll over and shut up about this well
that's not who i am i believe very
deeply that we are all obligated to
speak out when injustices occur in our
society and so i intended as soon as i
got fired to very loudly and proudly
tell everybody about what happened to me
because i think we live in a very
perverse and sick society tucker
when a young woman from a working class
background with parents who didn't go to
college can't criticize the outfit of
the most powerful woman in the united
states and worse than that the most
powerful woman in the united states is
actually considered the marginalized
victim in this scenario
you know i was you beat me to it i was
going to point that out
so the most powerful woman in the united
states is the marginalized victim and
the big soulless creepy woke company
takes her side using i assume it's hr
department because that's usually their
nkvd yeah i'd be happy to share the
names of the two people who actually
called me to fire me so jeff bowden is
the vice president of cumulus operations
in washington dc kristin fansellas is
the vice president of the human
resources department for cumulus and
they told me straight up on this phone
call that they believed that the kamala
harris tweet about her outfit was in
fact racist and violated this vague
social media policy that basically says
you can't do anything that would bring
reputational harm upon the company which
just means that they put that in there
so that they can fire people for any
reason that they want
did i mean i guess this is a rhetorical
question but did they explain how it was
racist
that you weren't impressed by your
outfit did they get specific or they
just call you names and fire you no they
just called me names and fired me and i
tried to defend myself but wasn't really
offered the opportunity and i'm told
that in subsequent meetings about this
situation they actually admitted that
they didn't really think that the tweet
was racist what really mattered to them
was the perception of it being racist by
these really bad faith dishonest
left-wing actors
okay can you repeat after me because i
know you're now looking for work kamala
harris looks bold beautiful and sassy
tonight
kamala harris i can't do it tucker
i hope someone hires you and soon i know
the spectator already has amber great to
see you tonight thank you thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight